how do you do you what do you say like
do you say like this helps us give us
the experiences right you you spin it
you spend it as this is the best for the
Xbox brand and again I say I I fir Messi
he know go ahead you gotta you gotta
snitch you got so you to right all the
time let me hear this what they gon say
I just I firmly believe that they
Messiah if listen when you think about I
I don't know how much they spend on R&D
on these ciles and what you know in
terms of over like what they consider to
be too much for a space where they feel
they plateaued in um and my hope is that
they truly understand and realize that
the strength of the Xbox brand lies in
the console base